yeah Jack and Larry the theme song that
was cool that's all what don't let me
forget that I danced nuts he's singing
this you know he went to LA a couple
weeks ago did what to do like promo and
stuff and to do the shows out there the
entire time we're out there driving
around in the hotel elevator in my head
for months everywhere we went
he's singing don't let me forget that I
dance don't let me forget that I dance
that's the beginning middle and end of
the song and he made it out is that
front
noth-nothing it's even more offensive
yeah I mean to the point and it's so
contagious that I think I told you
already the other day I was like out
with my wife like shopping or doing
something yeah and she goes so good days
she goes yep you spent [ __ ] two days
and hotel room with a guy that's what it
was she heard it in LA she was out there
and she goes um there was something I
wanted to remember and I was like what
she was like that I danced good no Jess
I know no we're not even trying to show
the the dance move with it it's like
it's because it's a song of rebellion it
is yeah and tell assault anger and
rebellion well I heard there was a remix
well what's that what's the dance move
that we go are you gonna start doing it
you're right you're I just showed just
show Nick I won't want your son it's
just so now it just happens it's anger
driven it's like this I'm already
embarrassed for you but I've everything
already like I got douche chills already
it's good because Jim's got a sweatshirt
you're gonna put this on snapchat or
something no don't do it all the kids
will be doing it'll be on social media
snapchat and Instagram and we'll put a
Twitter video up to Jim is like prepping
his arms no it's really simple oh he's
got his head up I can't do this I can't
do it what [ __ ] you
I like I'm so chilled out it's a thing
I'm literally getting chills up my arm
like it's like yeah I'm getting jitters
it's all I guarantee it's give me
disability it's one thing it's like this
don't let me forget that I died
[ __ ] [ __ ] is that little poop come
out of my pants
like this I'll do it into the camera
don't let me wait hold on ah you ready
don't let me forget that I danced oh my
god
wait you don't like it I want to see you
do that the shower and slip so [ __ ]
bad you don't like it no I can't believe
it I'm sitting down and a sailor from
the next show yeah man it's just what
you do is it your walk no you do when
you walk to someone no sound like this
you're walking don't let me forget that
I danced up what he does is he takes us
that when he gets aggressive he takes a
step forward and he points his fingers
straight out and he jabs them forward am
i less you like yeah I saw it you didn't
see like you know what's really like
disturbing about this yeah it's good Jim
you like it's good
Jim texted me a week ago yeah and he
goes I don't know if you're gonna like
the new aggressive remix if don't let me
forget that I danced he sits in his
apartment and he acts this stuff comes
out no here's how come it's nothing
acting it out I literally would just
looked in the mirror one day what don't
let me forget that I danced um
[ __ ] you and I'm gonna hit me up in the
air hit who are you talking to in you're
saying it alone you don't know but it
and the lyric is saying don't let me
forget right whoever whoever would let
me forget is that like your wife and you
have Alzheimer's as know what a
particular if people let me if I forget
that I danced it's kind of on them
what are you the white Kanye stop this
washing exhausted listening will I put
on my Doctor Who galini's and do my door
abelian solve rebellion